i always felt a little misplaced
[Music]
but i found this thing that i loved
and i had so much more to prove
whenever i would go people would just be
mooing
the crowd was pretty rough you do it
weird
he skated as if he was being operated by
a puppeteer
it reminded me that i can't even fit
into the skateboard world
the control he had was insane
[Music]
i was obsessed and i became a machine
that was the beginning of his launch to
become tony hawk
i was just rushed into adulthood
i never thought i'd be famous
but it's the worst drug
watching tony learn is more interesting
than watching him land tricks
i was truly alone
and had to go make a change
i had not figured out how to be a
husband or father because i didn't know
how to live my own skin
tony is always competing against tony
that's all just guts
it inspires us to do something different
i'm still trying to figure this out and
i never wanted to back down from the
challenge
i'm not gonna quit
[Music]
you